okay so we like to say the organizers
for giving me the opportunity to give a
more comments matter oriented talk this
meeting at least more consumer-oriented
at the previous ones but there will be
some tension network and stuff so i will
talk about the how one can study the
doping of know some categories of spin
liquids with peps and that's the work
that we just submit put on the archiver
recently just a few days ago so done in
collaboration with Philip Goebbels no
Bircher and Ignacio Iraq so I will be
mainly talking about that but I would
like to make the parallel with some
former work where we look at the
different thing but still with a lot of
analogy so here it's about
superconductors which have to do with
breaking of a continuous human symmetry
which is the charge you want symmetry
and the analogues are basically some
magnetic system were the actually the SE
symmetry the conservation of se symmetry
around the magnetic field direction is
broken so there is a clear parallel
between the two aspects so I will start
with some motivation so motivation is
basically the trying to understand i TC
superconductors so it's a very old
problem from the late 80s so the
materials have been discovered in 87 and
these materials are basically two
dimensional strongly correlated systems
on the square lattice so for the purpose
of this talk will just consider we have
s qualities and the phase diagram is a
following so we have temperature and we
have some axis which is the
stoichiometry of the material which
correspond to the doping of Mott
insulator so x equals zero correspond to
insulator which mean I have one particle
per site on average and at this point i
have only basically only on this point i
have only spin degrees of freedom in the
problem so i can consider you know that
i gather some energy scale for the
charging citation which is the charge
gap which is very very large compared to
all you know all parameters in the
problem like the bandwidth or the
magnetic coupling constant so i can
forget about the charge degrees of
freedom and then i will charge the
circuitry of the material and then i
will introduce charge so this is what we
call dopey and now the charge these
three of charge degrees of freedom
repealing the problem and the goal is to
try to see whether we can understand
that with unique tensile network and how
we can actually introduce this charge
agrees of freedom into the problem
assuming we have a tensile network
description for the Mott insulator okay
so that's basically the goal so the
question is can we could the small D
peps let's say describe or give
reasonably good
so that's actually defined but
description of the what happens and of
course we are along this line so we are
really you know targeting zero
temperatures ooh so really looking at
the ground state property so now it's
known that doping an NT 4 magnet is a
complete complicated problem and so far
we haven't really started to do that so
the hint to make things a little bit
simpler and get a simpler starting point
as a noted for magnet is basically to
introduce magnetic frustration in the
problem so I want to choose my little
frustration so it means i will have some
other axis here okay which is my
magnetic fish situation so it will be
for example the ratio of two magnetic
coupling constant which i call j 1 over
J 2 so on this qualities you would
correspond to know the ratio between
this anti ferromagnetic coupling
constant and the anti ferromagnetic
coupling constant on the diagonal of the
placket and what is we expect and
actually it's known that this is the
case that if I am in the T equals 0
plane actually the anti ferromagnetic
order parameter goes away when I
increased frustration so there is a line
here that goes to 0 basically so when i
get to some point which is around j 2 /
j 1 equal point 5 which is here then i
get quantum disordered state which is a
spin liquid so this point with spindle
quid and this stay we can describe with
a very simple peps okay so j 2 / j 1
when I increase it I can stabilizers be
liquid which we can describe
as a pet and this perhaps is an RV be
state which I will define later and we
have a simple peps description and
actually it's very simple it's d equal
three bond dimension so it means we can
basically calculate many things even
doing me no contraction exactly on small
systems this is an exact statement this
is the ground state of the exact
reminisce later dunno it's done the
exact roadside but you it's very I mean
we are done you know simulation cap
computed energies it's very good energy
and you can refine it I mean there is a
we can construct a one-dimensional
family no one parameter family of states
playing with the low branch you no
longer range balls and we get very good
energy comparable to what the emoji yes
what is j1 j2 model which I will be fine
so so dimm Aziz is the placket VBSS the
lava state or the so they have been
claims that it's a seafood maybe a zero
spin liquid but this I I don't believe i
believe maybe you know there is some
columnar face I mean what happens on
this side is complicated but I believe
here there is some call on the face and
there is either reverse now ranch where
it's topological split liquid well there
is one point where just critical point
and our state I will show you but the RV
diste we are constructing as actually
has critical diver correlation so that's
visibly good starting point if we are
just sitting at the treatment for it so
they're a blessing liquid it would be a
gap by spinning yeah because we are the
bipartite matrix and it's at the level
of we believe that yeah right right but
i will show you you know comparison is
more elaborated cook
using iPads for example by and the point
is that even if you know you might have
a very good lot insulator here the point
is that when you dope the state we are
going to construct is going to be better
actually that's a surprising fact but
it's getting better and better actually
do okay so so what is a strategy
basically once again you're getting
better what I do is my answers so I will
start to know so this is I was going to
say how I do it so so i will have an ads
ads for x equals 0 which is our vb state
and then there is a very simple physical
you know using physical intuition
basically you can construct nine shots
for the dope case and when you compared
to for example ipads calculation then
you see that actually add fun i don't
aim it's better than actually at zero
degree so i will show you a plot idea if
i have time showing that
so the strategy is the following so we
start one we start with from the X equal
0 rd be spinning played okay and then
what we have to do is we to use charge
it with of freedom so we are basically
to enlarge the physical fill the space
of the state okay 4x different from 0
okay by what we like to do is to do this
but keeping the bond dimension D fixed
okay because my still might want to do
we know calculations on on finite
systems of reasonable size and be able
to investigate properties of this thing
and I will show you that actually we
have a construction which does that is
just enlarging the physical hippo space
which was looking without doing anything
to the bone dimension so without
introducing more and tournament in the
depends so that basically the strategy
now now some remarks
so first first remark doping is not a
small perturbation
and for example if i start with spin
liquid which has topological order like
and we have on the cargo melodies for
example then if I dope I will impress
upon immediately lose your topological
character so it's very related to what
villa was no explaining this morning
like your temperature effect or doping
effect on basically same the other
remark is that if I introduce charge
agrees of freedom okay there is an
emerging so I don't know village i can
write down or everybody can see or okay
okay to an emerging you one symmetry
which is actually associated to the
conservation of the charge ok so this
charge you want symmetry and the
symmetry actually can be broken and this
is what we've seen our answers and so we
get a superconducting state which is
exactly what it is when you one charge
symmetry is broken so we get a super
critical state and this happens actually
immediately when we introduce your chart
equivalent in the power which is the
nice thing about it so this is really
the idea of starting from the rdb here
from the spin liquid that we can get
immediately a superconductor well if we
would start from the RT from nine net we
know that what happens no between the
antiferromagnetic state at zero doping
and the superconducting state here is a
complicated thing that is much more
difficult to describe so here we believe
it's much simpler what happens and there
is basically the superconducting state
that basically originates from the
underlying pairing contained in the
artistic and the third point is that
because we are introducing charge agrees
of freedom then we have to take you to
account fermionic statistics
so even though we start with the bosonic
type of state at zero doping when we
have basically to introduce a feminine
character and the easiest way to do is
basically to first rewrite the RB b
state in the insulator in the insulating
phase using the firm unique
representation and so then it will be
very natural to extend the state i
thought i do p okay so that's basically
the strategy but before we do that I
would like to first discuss the second
part which is actually simpler because
here I we don't we're not dealing with
extra degrees of freedom like the child
agrees of freedom and we are not not
also dealing with the fact that we have
to introduce from unique statistics but
there are many we can draw a parallel
with the previous problem so what I will
try to do first is to look at what i
call the magnetic analog
so so the idea is basically that for
example if i consider system of spin one
half for example of frustrated magnette
i can use the odd core.bos own
representation of my speed okay so i
always say for example zero boson would
correspond to adding spin up one ball
zone which I obtained by applying is
both operation operator of the state
correspond coming what I use the other
way shows you've been down so this one
will correspond espinado and assume i
introduce a magnetic field which are i
say it's which i can choose along the Z
direction then the Zeeman energy which
is minus H sum of all the sides SI Z in
can be written in the bottom language as
your chemical potential which involved
the density of bosons okay so there is
this basically so while I will crank up
the magnetic field it's like you know
changing the chemical potential and
doping the system okay so there is this
nice parallel so now i am again you one
symmetry in the problem which is the
conservation of the total magnetization
along the Z direction and that's you
know similar to the UN symmetry which is
which will correspond to the
conservation of the total charge okay so
so these the magnetization along the Z
direction which I call em is conserved
so it is defined by one of Earth number
of sides sum of all the side of
tradition value of si si and what I
expect if I start from a gap spin the
grid
what I expect basically is to observe
above some critical magnetic field the
phase transition so this M will rise up
to saturation which in this case is what
up to all the spin will be up magnetic
field and this type actually is a
superfluid because this day actually
breaks also this UN symmetry so this is
the analog actually of the
superconductor and so super fluid so it
has a finite value of the of this
operator of the both question operator
and if now I translate back to the speed
language means that the expectation
value of Assad plus will be different
from zero okay and SI plus sub- i can
make e that actually tell me that the
spin component in the plane as a finite
value so i am basically a staggered i
will have if i have a bipartite lattice
i will have a struggle mai tais a shin
transverse to the magnetic field
direction okay so and that's really the
analog of the superconducting state and
so this we can actually study and i will
give you an example so i will start i
will start with the sun'll tonian like
some su 2 environment iron which is for
example the AK Artyom atonia make it
simple and i will start with the ex
agonal lattice ok so as you may have an
example i can t amo tanya on the exam
lattice so here i am dealing with
actually spin three half here and the
italian will just be the sum of our
all nearest neighbor bones of the
projector on those bones to the spin
three okay so the usual a celtic cross
faction and then i will add some
magnetic field ok so this discard the
same i'm cappy so for this part we know
how to construct the taps it's a very
simple it's a d equal to that's and then
i will construct some simple and thats
to understand you know how you go with a
magnetic field so maybe i will show some
sighs okay so so this is basically the
left hand side so i have my example
lackeys and the peps construction is
very is actually very simple so i have
to wait to do this and see that state so
here i will have on every every side
which are speed three fi break it in
three spin one out and then the a coyote
construction is identical to actually
the best construction so i will consider
the maximally entangled state which are
the same lights on the balls and then
the answer is obtained by applying your
projection on these are on the sides
that maps this virtual space on to the
physical space which is the spins we
have obviously it is the max completely
symmetric it not see to the completely
symmetric subspace so that's my hands
out for zero magnetic field and i can
also consider something which will be of
interest later which is the now the on
the same lattice but now it's it's a
spin one half RVD state and i have a
construction which is very similar so
the pets construction for the RV be so
what is the rdb first ERBB is
basically considering that every spin
one half so now these are spin one half
every spin one up on the side is
actually part of the dimer okay so on
every side there is a dimer so there is
dimers between all the side of the
nuggies and the RVD is just a linear
superposition of all of them with the
same weight so this is equal weight
superposition of this newest neighbor
cygnet coverings and it turns out that
on this bipartite lattice it is critical
so it has long branch diamond armor
correlation although it has short range
spin spin correlation so the
construction now the pets construction
is very similar so I have now to
introduce another virtual state which is
the two-state professor is now it's a
depo three state to represent the fact
that on some of the bones there are no
singlets ok so now on these the project
projector actually maps these three
states here of the LC laws on to now the
spin one off this set off this case why
another Xperia but otherwise it's very
similar so now I can look at what
happens if i add the magnetic field and
can i come up with a very simple
description so how are we going by the
way how are we going to deal with these
states while IM is basically to do
calculation with these pets and so our
general scheme is to put these pets on a
cylinder and since the virtual space is
is the as a small dimension d we can
basically do exact construction we can
also use you know approximate scheme but
what is nice is that we can basically
four cylinders which are not too large
but which are similar to what the
imagine people use you know
typically six eight or ten unit cell in
the transverse direction we can actually
do exact construction they compute you
know observable for those things and
what is nice also is that we can
basically consider the limit where the
lights of the cylinder is infinite
because the way to do it is to so so
what we do basically is we construct the
double layer pets taking the cat and the
bra and so this we do on a first on a
column here so that gives a transfer
matrix so we contract the physical
indices we get the transfer matrix and
then we can iterate the transfer matrix
from left to right up to infinity so
basically we are finite size affect only
the transverse direction but we'll get
rid of the true for a size effect in the
longitudinal direction let's basically
be asking so now we this is where we are
going to use to compute observables and
so so our way am I going to extend my
pets to account for the effect of the
magnetic field actually it's very easy
so in the case of the echo lt1 simple
very simple construction keeping the
bomb dimension the same that is to is
just consider that because of the
magnetic field I will have a mixture of
the of the singlet with the one one
component of the triplet which is around
magnetic field okay a dieta will be a
virtual parameter that will depend on
the magnetic field and then we can
adjust it looks a very crude but i will
show you actually comparison with
lactose Xavier ization we show that this
adult is extremely good now what will
happen for the RVD case for the rtb
cases it's kind of different we know
that if we
the magnetic field will like to promote
for example some of the bones above the
single bound into triplets but actually
we know that in such a state the
excitation of fractional excitation so
it means if I make a triplet excitation
then they would like to fractional eyes
like an basically what you mentioned and
so basically i will end up with you know
spin one half excitation which are spin
on excitation so this we we can actually
include at the level of the other pets
and so what we do is we simply add a new
projector okay to the state so now we
consider that we have a projector p1
which is a spin on projector that
actually maps no.33 to state into a spin
one half which is polarized along the
magnetic field so maybe i can write this
down make pure maybe
so so for the rdd what I do is I
basically take the usual RVD projector
look at 40 minded field and I add a new
piece so lambda P 1 so that correspond
to adding new tensor elements on the
site and this p1 is basically equal to
these projections so it basically start
with 3 and seals which are in the two
states okay which mean there is no
dimers on the bones and then project it
on the spin one half which is in
directional magnetic field so that
exactly is P known that the crudest
think you can think of to to write a
spin home and so the nice thing is that
basically we are the same Boogie mansion
again these in these advanced which is a
first point and the second point is just
by construction you break the UN
symmetry
associated to the conservation amazing
okay so that's clear here i mean this
this clearly is a mixture between a
single eye on the ball with the triplet
component ok so you bravely you want to
make me in this indesign thoughts so you
expect to have to see some transverse
magnetization which correspond to come
to some super afraid order parameter or
careful for this problem so it's the
same as the superfluid other primate oh
okay yes so so then you have an answer
to pets which is traditionally valued by
construction right so much rate is
emitted by construction that's right so
it's not a prediction it's not a result
of of intimidation is it just right
except you have to optimize for every
magnetic field you have to you know you
have a family of effects so for every
line in the field this beta parameter in
one case or you have this lambda
parameter in the other case so there
would be a function of the magnetic
field so there is an optimization at
this level you have done one parameter
family right but only for lambda equal
to zero you'll get no breaking on magic
of you once that's right that's right so
immediately as soon as you can turn all
this land lambda beta you will get super
fluid density okay and so let me just
show you how good it is for the case of
the a Canadian opinion so what we show
here is the energy per side as a
function of the magnetization okay so so
the magnetic field you know if I have
the energy is written as this energy per
site okay minus the magnetic field time
the magnetization and this guy is a
function of the magnetization long
duration okay so and so to get the
magnetization as a function of field you
have to do others on transform okay so
this is your usual things so basically
you minimize these forgiven filled with
respect to the magnetization and what
you get is that the magnetic field is
minus the derivative of the energy which
in this case is a dirty energy with
respect to the magnetization so if I
give you this curve which is the energy
per site as a function of reduced
magnetization then I can draw the
magnetization curve that is
magnetization versus magnetic field
which is the curve I draw I've drawn
before okay which I erased opportunity
okay so what what what data then we plot
here so we plot function cigs ionization
on six inside so it is that in easy
calculation because we have four state
per side no like herbert so so in there
like four to the 16 state in the other
space so it's not a big but nevertheless
we can you do it using you know
symmetries and these are the dots okay
and the the other points are the answers
get the grid points in the game points
and they are actually quite good for
such crude you know adults and so from
from this equation you can get the
critical field because the critical
field correspond to the initial slope
here 40 magnetization okay so the slope
here goes linear and
slope is a critical field and the
critical field was fined for the from
the eggs ionization is actually very
close to your critical theory five with
using these epsom salts considering the
fact that just a simple d equal two
enzymes yes what's the difference
between the green and the purple light
okay I didn't want to go to the two into
too much detail but we have actually two
parameters so so we are not only mixing
the triplet on the bones but we also
actually introducing some we are also
increasing the bond dimension there is
little more complicated and that's but
it's just a bit technical but it doesn't
do much you know the the these data are
just with the answers are showing is
these purple
okay so so just to show you that is
doing well considering the you know the
simple nature of the on the engines and
of course what we find is and we can
calculate it on infinite cylinders is
the transverse magnetization which you
correspond to this superfeet order
parameter as a function of the reduced
magnetization and you see that as soon
as the magnetization is done 0 then we
have super fit density which has is this
for me we can calculate it in the
industry this formalism okay so now i
would like to come back to my first
motivation which is the charge doping
so you will see that it is actually very
similar and we can borrow you know for
the construction of the dot RvB we can
borrow some of the ideas that we have
here it is in this construction for the
doctor vegan for the magnetic
magnetically dope targeting
okay so just to get an idea of what we
are interested in we we can so what we
do basically is we have don't in here
okay we have Chris tration and as a
function of frustration so basically
this one from Norfolk reading the note
facility system is active for magnetic
roller and a different magnetic order
and as I was telling you this is killed
by the frustration so for frustration of
all around point five and then the idea
now is to see what happens if I start
from this point and I dope the system so
the amatory I'm gonna consider as a
guide okay this is basically a j-1 we
call j 1 j 2 T model or so which is just
the anti ferromagnetic coupling along
the nearest neighbor and next year
stable bomb so i have this permit oj 14
News neighbor and je to fajn next
newspaper
and then I'm going to consider that some
of the sides are diluted okay so there's
basically holes or empty sides okay and
so these are the charge agrees of
freedom and this child agrees of freedom
can actually de la lies on the lattice
will have some hopping term associated
to them so there is a term hot in term
which is like the usual time binding
form but now what is new here is that I
have strong I assume a very strong
correlation on the sides so if an
electron hops on the adjacent side I
don't want it creates a WIP by side
because that caused an enormous energy
okay so an electron can help at a given
side only if there is a hole next to it
okay and so I have to induce some
projector to guarantee this which is
called the guts little projector and
this projector formally is just given by
the product you can write it as a
product on all the sides of one- and I
up and I don't okay so each time I have
a configuration which only one side as a
WIP by side this projector justin is you
okay so that Garrett is a viable space
has no WK Python it's a TJ model by
where i have used chris tration so it's
like a key j 1 j 2 morrow okay
so what i will do is i will start how
much time you're 15 minutes a little
more so i would start with the bosonic
RvB state at x equals 0 so but by our vb
I mean the state so now i am its
qualities an order on the exam or
lattice and by RvB I mean the equal
weight superposition of the odd core
values one covering ok so I have
construction figuration went on every
four well every side as a dimer attached
to it ok so on every side i will have
the dimer like that and this is empty
this is it ok so that's a constraint
every side there is a the diner in a
single one and what I have to do is I
will I can't reduce charging with a
freedom which are from your knee so what
I'm going to do is to rewrite the RGB
state in the familiar presentation
okay so i get a sense state but now i
will use fx2 writing so it's exactly
said state by a different representation
and then now when I have revived in the
carminic representation I can just
simply take out articles okay so that
would be a simple generalization so I
can immediately introduced charge
degrees of freedom
so this is really essential i rewrite my
state in the phonetic representation
even for x equals zero
so
so so the RV be state let me write it
again so this is the sum one
configurations like like that so I have
enough of qualities and I construct my
balance ball configuration like that and
i sum over them with the same equal
weight and equal sign plus 1 everywhere
and we know that this can be represented
as i explained with the d equal 3 pax is
a ball dimension 3 and now i have only
physical dimension to okay spin up and
spin down on every side so what I will
so the the tensor are basically like
five weeks no I mean if I have that's a
very simple so on three of the bones I
have the two state and in one of the
bone layer 0 either 0 or 1 that
correspond to spin up or spin down on
the physical index so that's my project
ok that's it rather then I want to
rewrite these in terms of the fermium so
what does it mean it means basically
that I have to create these dimers i can
introduce we write the operator that
create the dimers in terms of fermions
so are we write it as so this is I and J
i rewrite it as CR up tiger CJ dagger
plus CJ up dagger see
I will do sit down sweetie I don't tiger
that's my singlet operator which now in
the feminine presentation is symmetric
so this is f ji okay so while here I
have to use a convention you know it's a
basilica presentation I have basically
to use a convention from A to B sub like
this because this guy is a down- down up
and so it is anti symmetric with respect
to the reflection okay but now in the
fermion I don't need to do that anymore
okay just become symmetric but the price
I have to pay if I use these I basically
are introduced some sign in the wave
function and the way to see this easiest
way is basically to consider into a
simple RvB configuration on four sides
we're going to take four sides and I
write the configure this configuration
ok so so in the bosonic representation I
have some arrows so let's say that this
guy Plus this guy ok you can check that
if you rewrite this in terms of this
operator basically you will get this so
now I don't have any more arrows because
it's symmetric minus this ok so if i
rewrite this wave function in terms of
this new fermionic operator ok i have a
very non-trivial sign that appears here
ok and so how do we fix this sign the
answer is very simple to fig this sign
we can just say that minus one is just
it working i square ok and so what i
will do is each time i have so i think
maybe there is a minus here and across
here so here while it depends what
comments on YouTube but assume there is
a minus here so this is i square and so
what I do is basically I split this
minus sign in terms of
two bones so each time we have a
vertical bone in my configuration I put
enough okay so i can write plus and then
I and I ok so that and this will
automatically take care of the of the
minus sign so I can use the earth pets
now introducing the saying that you know
each up and down spin are actually
electrons with up and down spin and
there are fermions now and so I can use
all the technology which have been
developed for to construct f F maps so I
build a transparency from Philippe where
it sites you know all the words so
probably I get there many people here
will participate it to setting this up
and so we're going to just use the one
of these formulation and include this I
few so what gets exactly the same state
but now it's written in the in the firm
your own representation ok and so now
it's very easy to do dope so now we have
the RV me liquid written and tons of
trans which is yes so if you have not
done that if you just take the fermionic
representation we write the eyes is that
all times x-4 if I have what if you just
I don't know the energy is very done
it's very very yeah if you forget about
the I will you may put a plus sign and
then you use famille then it's awful and
Italy understand why one works rather
than the other one so well because it's
interestedly abbas onic problem at half
filipino so so it's all over as well no
you can't you can look at you know the
what where the Heisenberg Hamiltonian
that yeah maybe the answer is a
following simplest answer is you take
four sides and you look at what the
eisenberg on the turret does or the same
let and that actually it's is doing this
nozzle flip of the dimers with a plus
sign so you can check out sign your
paper exactly
right so you can understand it at the
level of the placket of the resonance of
the placket dimension say I think it
follows yeah it follows a marshal son
yes yes education yes right well but no
as soon as you add frustration here you
principal you should not I mean there's
no reason why you should have the
emotional side but it turns out i think
this wave function could feel the
emotional side but it need not feasible
okay so so this is what we we start with
that ok so now there is an eye
everywhere and this is the f maps there
is no orientation of the of the vault
and we think of no it really introducing
dokie so basically what we can do I mean
simply adjust with tails inside ok so i
can need to do some tensor that
correspond to that which is very very
simple that correspond to the hole so
that that would be basically some dancer
so i will have some new projector i'm
doing like like you know the previous
example so i'm taking zero and then i
would add some lambda times p1 and this
projector correspond to this tensor
element well here I have a new physical
state which is this to stay so these two
these are the empty you know the vacant
site if you want the holes and then I
say that there is no dime there is no
singlets around it ok and so I would
have to hear for the virtual indices so
that's a new projector I can just make
now extendable space include the holes
and add this and add this projector ok
so if naively this is what you would do
but the problem is that if you do that
you can when you calculate the
expectation value of
eastern the kinetic term so in this wave
function where you have just added this
piece you find that the kinetic energy
is just 0 and this is exact and why is
it zero it is 0 basically because this
operator wants to move the whole to the
next place / 1 along the near single
bolt and if you want to move the holes
here basically you have to create a
singlet on the diagonal of the diagonal
of the packet okay and it turns out that
this new configuration is orthogonal to
all the configuration of my heart
indistinct this you can improve because
that involves an infinitely long stream
that that gives a nap orthogonality with
all the previous thing so it means that
if I really want to describe that I have
to be a little more pepper and I have to
include some configuration where in the
vicinity of the holes I have some longer
runs bones okay so basically they see
what we are doing with this projector
here i will add some other projector so
with some coefficient c which is a
virtual parameter times a projector p 2
and this projector actually so i will
not writing it's basically that what it
does is that it includes configuration
where it's the vicinity of a hole I
around the world ball also this type of
configuration or all the symmetric ones
like that that's all and it also has
some configuration where if I have a
hole here I will have a singlet that
goes above
the whole so this is what this projector
does and it has no I don't need to
extend the bond dimension you can
construct this by keeping the bond
dimension giveth freely kids raised
that's very easy so I basically no price
you can consider this wave function so
the thing that internally goes through
that side the signature is crossing for
it to the first new addition is happen
yes so it's internally it's going
through the internship exactly is some
kind of teleportation thing we can you
can include by saying that if I have a
zero here i can either one if you
musically and so that guarantees and so
now there is this issue about the
respective weight of of those but we
figured out what what you choose so so
if you do that you are basically one
priority family of state and you can
optimize with respect to this parameter
okay so if you increase seed then you
can actually get lower and lower kinetic
energy and and then you have this
parameter lambda which is actually like
a chemical potential that choose the
hole density okay so you have one
version parameter to lower the energy in
another parameter to tune the density of
holes so that's basically the idea
basically no price okay and so since I
got much time maybe I show you the
results so that's basically another type
of configuration
introduced and so what we compute it is
so this is computed at infinite
cylinders which have seats or eight no
unique we need cell in the the
transverse direction and this is as a
function of doping and this is a kinetic
energy per hole so this is something
that we know from eggs idolization in
the old days we know what should be the
kinetic energy per hole when you'd open
market you later and that's basically of
the order of minus 2t purple so that's
the number that comes out from the
launch of circulation smokers so this we
can reproduce I mean when we increase
the parameter c you see that here the
kinetic energy powell is getting as low
as minus 2.5 t and we know that that's
it is right order of 92 days so the
simple answers can can understand can
can you believe that and so the last
point we need to understand is basically
what the nature of the what the nature
of the phase we are and basically when
we find with that this thing is a
superconductor
so how can we see that
so the first hint that we have the
superconductor is coming from the fact
that we can define another promoter for
it and we can actually change the face
of the superconducting order parameter
by playing with the with the face of the
chemical potential in the adults so what
does it mean means that i can define the
superconducting pairing which is the
dictation value of CI set up so that's
typically two sides on nearest neighbor
position or next news neighbor position
and this is a singlet operator so that
correspond to a coupe repair in the
system okay and this is different from
you just by construction okay and you
can see that we can actually change the
face of this guy in the wave function so
what is that because I have a projector
which is p0 plus lambda cons t1 plus CP
2 and these guy basically maps on the
stay which are the spin and these two
projector map on states which are home
okay so if i change the face of lambda 2
lambda i phi in fact you can convince
yourself that you will change the face
of this expectation value by
we go into exponential to i-5 but that
idea okay so that's the explicit you
want symmetry breaking in the indie FX
okay so the phase here is that you
introduced in the pets correspond
actually to the superconducting phase of
your super conductor so that's very easy
to adjust by construction so what you
can do with that you can do all sorts of
thing for example you can calculate how
the superconducting order parameter
appears as a function of misciagna two
minutes yeah we started late later two
minutes later so how the superconducting
order parameter appears as a function of
doping so what you see that it basically
it appears immediately when you drove
the system it appears immediately at any
finite doping so you can even try to
feed the dependence on the
superconducting varying amplitude let me
see what I short here so this is a
parent amplitude on the near stable
sides and you see that basically goes
like a square root of the popular thing
so the different curves correspond to
different parameter see that we have the
answers and what you see also is that
there is a nexus never component so
there is pairing on the next news
neighbor sides and you can also make
orbital you know you could compute the
orbital symmetry of your the perimeter
and see that actually the other
perimeter as the gwave component so
that's in the old you know winfield rd
that's what what's coming out but the
new point is that there is a small
imaginary component that we get here
which has a square signature so this guy
is very small compared to this one but
we can argue that it should still be
there because basically it is contained
you know it originates from the RV be in
the Mott insulator because they are
between the mountains remainder are
despite the eye on the vertical bolt and
so there is this either you know mix
symmetry esposa de or depose is repose
is symmetry is Eden will be insulating
oughta be so what I mean by either is
that there is no superconducting
amplitude in the insulator of course but
there is this phase factor between the
horizontal bond and the vertical mode so
as soon as you're dope then the
superconductor basically in Aries from
this deep rose is symmetry of the
insulator so so so basically there
should be this small component and this
is a time you know reversal symmetry
breaking component which might have some
little application with the real
material that is it is actually personal
so we don't
it's physical or not so maybe some out a
Luke is that now whether we like to do
is basically to try to understand what
would happen if we don't get you from A
game so can we actually extend this
construction to the antiferromagnetic
case which is harder but we know how to
construct actually the pets for the
Attic for my head and what would happen
how if I do on these and this time
that's the next problem interesting okay
thank you very much so so let's say
you've presented designers which has a
superconductor if you're patient with
the end yes and in some particular the
Lionel what was that when you had zero
doping yes then you have you related
that independence yes I forgot to answer
one of the question that was asked I
said it's better way it's dope and so we
have actually comparison with I peps
which I forgot to show but this is the
last slide actually and so these are the
iPads calculation from Philippe which
are the do the glue dots and these are
the hour ends at switch are these this
point so you see that they are actually
if you start from a random configuration
and you do the you know you do the
simple update algorithm with a cent bomb
dimension d equal three then you never
managed to reach the you know the energy
of the an service is it with you one
symmetry is is that is not using any any
particular constraint i think is using
random initial condition and so
he has a more general answer than yours
yeah because he's starting and he never
managed to get down to 22 my answers for
all the points except at half inning but
is it it's incorrect to say that if you
have a proper updated p minus 20 device
properly it much I hope so but so what
you did no but what he did is he uses a
pony yeah but there is another thing
that he put you know it uses my answers
you know as a starting point of these
iPads thing and and you try to optimize
it further and you never managed you so
these are the green dots here which I
obtained by taking as an initial
configuration the exits graph and then
trying to optimize it further and you
see that it's basically on the same time
okay so so it means it's an optimal I
think it's a very close to the optimal
state for d equal 30 maybe this is a
statement about simple update yeah yes I
would you like a fellow update this will
probably change I mean we know that
there are cases my simple update goes
okay this receives mean exactly up here
his heavy trifold update not yet i think
there is a technical complication which
is the thing that we have to deal with
longer lunch magnetic interaction oh
there's no full update for the diagram
well then maybe you can you can set it
up but you know that's really hard to do
it for long dated yes yeah probably
harder it would yes and once once he
goes to the photo 6 and give it to the
energy I mean yeah this is what you saw
all other people he is there any it's a
completely different state so these
those states are kind of of charge order
you know it it does there are no uniform
state so I'm not going to be a supporter
of simple update but you're saying that
there is a little pencil page with
energy which are completely different
yeah no no but what he says is that you
know if you do this simple update and
try to crank up the bomb dimension then
eventually this chart order thing
finance non-uniform will disappear so so
that's an artifact of the I peps at
small the small one dimension that you
get a stay which is not meaningful but I
think it will it will go it will go away
when you increase the bond dimension but
the energy is also will keep dropping
yeah yeah all right as expected but I
mean it's different in a very big and
top 10% here that's been here
these are energetic saw some tea Jay Jay
fine that's right that's exactly the
problem i don't know this is funny
strong in a way which only show the 45
yes so the bullpen we should probably
move on that next